charte d'adoption de deux poules
pondeuses
grâce à ce document une douzaine de
familles de villepreux vont pouvoir
accueillir chez elle
un couple de poule aujourd'hui première
réunion d'information la famille petit
wayne fait partie des candidats
sélectionnés
on en a discuté évidemment avec ma femme
et après avec avec les filles on était
ravi de t'avoir de savoir l'idée d'avoir
de poule 2 poule à la maison qui nous
qui nous donnent des oeufs et je trouve
que l'initiative en fait est vraiment
intéressante l'idée d'avoir des poules
dans le jardin également de le regarder
les laisse sortir les portes à tous oui
leur donner à manger chaud je l'aï dit
hier et tout une opération menée par la
ville pour la deuxième année
adoptez la poule attitude s'inscrit dans
une démarche écologique
l'objectif principal c'est la réduction
des déchets parce qu'avec une foule en
fête une poule mangent jusqu'à 70 75 kg
de déchets de cuisine parents donc avec
deux poules 150 kg de moins par an c'est
quand même conséquent saillie encore
c'est bon niveau de moins pour
accueillir ces petits composteurs à
plumes la famille s'active dans la
construction du poulailler la future
maison des nouvelles locataires déjà
très très joli très pratique avec plein
de verture qui vont nous faciliter la
tâche pour nettoyer le poulailler pour
lui donner à manger leur donner à manger
après une heure et demi de montage le
poulailler est fin prêt jenny molly
rejoigne la famille et découvrir leur
nouvel environnement
on sait ce qu'elle mange on sait quand
elles vont pondre
on sait de quoi ils sont faits c'est
noah qui viennent de nos jardins en fait
on les prend et on les mange c'est tout
à toutes les deux jenny et molly
réduiront 250 kg les déchets du foyer et
nourriront la famille une poule rousse
peut pondre jusqu'à 200 euros par an